[Music]
well thanks for doing this thank you for
making all the way up here to sit down
this is a long time coming I'm been
looking forward to this for a long time
me too it's an honor to be here you have
created quite the amazing organization I
want to get into like how this whole
thing happened and the intentionality
behind it it's super interesting so
first of all like congrats on what
you've manifested and created because
it's really truly something to behold
when I when I was going into Santa
Monica to meet our mutual friend Tom
Scott the other day I was supposed to
meet him at his hotel and at the last
second he's like meet me at this address
and I didn't know that that was
beautycounter and I'm like what is this
building you know nothing it opens up
into this whole amazing world your
fiefdom - I'm in my flip-flops I'm like
I feel underdressed in here you know
that's it come to work at the counties a
week do we have to be dressed up all the
time like now I just came from New York
I like to dress up sometimes right yeah
you wear whatever you want to so well
let's start at the beginning you are I
mean I think it's fair to say you're a
serial entrepreneur like this isn't your
first time at that like you've launched
successful companies in the past like
going back to like cleaning houses in
Nantucket like during college right like
it's all wait you've always had an
entrepreneurial Flair did you always
know that that was gonna be your path
you know I think when I started working
as a kid there were there was no real
definition around entrepreneurs and I
think now it's one of those things that
everyone talks about quote-unquote
entrepreneurs I just had ideas and I
needed to make money so those two things
tend to make you entrepreneur but it
wasn't like I'm gonna go get a job like
you wanted to start your own thing
I don't think I've ever done a
particularly good job of being part of a
big hierarchical structure and I think I
tend to want to operate more efficiently
and I don't like I like to cut out all
the red tape in the [ __ ] you know I
think that you you know for me when I
first started working when I was a kid
it was just how do i how can i what are
those things I can do to make some quick
money and that allow me to flexibility
and the cleaning company started because
I wanted to be able to go to the beach
we need to make a lot of money and you
know I knew I could clean houses but you
know I didn't want to go work in a store
where it was a set amount of I like
being in control of those types of
things I knew I could make money on my
own time and work as much or as little
as I wanted to and that the end result
would be of my doing and not because I
worked for $12 an hour in the store when
you were cleaning those houses was Tom
cruising around on a boat snowing juice
did those things overlap or was that a
different time you know he was cruising
around on a boat I wasn't cruising
around with him in a different place
today but yeah you know it was I was out
of Nantucket in the summer with my
college years because it was fun I mean
what it was such a different world back
then but everyone every single house
that was being painted every everything
that was happening on an Tekkit in those
days was being done by college kids and
it was a blast right so then you
graduate college and I don't know if
this story is true or apocryphal but
what I heard was that your mom wrote a
check for five grand and gave you a
briefcase and said here you go and
that's that's the end of it that is the
end of it I gave me a black briefcase
with SGR my initials on it and
monogrammed by the world you know my
mother had always felt my mother from
the from when I was a really little girl
had always said you need to be
financially independent and I'm gonna
get you through school and whether I
have the means with which to continue to
support you or not I'm not going to you
need to be able to stay on your own two
feet so she sent that message and it was
it was it was loud and clear I remember
saying to her that I wanted to move to
Australia or Hong Kong all these ideas
and she said great well you've got five
grand do with it what you will but she
wasn't at all prepared to give me any
more money and and didn't write and
still won't write so youyou went to New
York City and started a little business
and then quickly racked up a credit card
bill right and and she was she was like
all right well I guess it's time to get
a job a job I mean I got I graduated
from college after clean I cleaned the
summer after I graduated four so I had a
little money I had the $5,000 I got my
apartment going in the Upper East Side
of New York and I started an ad with an
advertising agency as an account manager
making like 19 grand a year but I was
you know going out and shopping I just
wasn't used to it also and I called my
mom I'd like a $2,000 and
and she's like uh get a new job I mean
that was that so I did and when does
well first of all sort of behind the
scenes growing up like he moved around a
lot right like he lived in lots of
different places and there was money and
then there wasn't money and my you know
my assumption is that kind of fueled
your desire to be financially
independent like and and and to not have
to you know whether some of those things
that you you had to deal with growing up
for sure I mean I think sometimes people
I would admit I have a unhealthy
relationship to money but it is a thing
for me in a way that I you know grew up
in a family that was from
well-positioned families and was doing
quite well in the beginning and then it
was all sort of stripped from out from
us and we were forced to move from place
to place and I mean look there people
have had far more challenging
circumstances but it does impact you
when you're constantly moving and you
have a father who's sick and your
parents are divorce and you're trying to
make ends meet and so for me I would say
people I'm not driven by money at all
but I am driven by the desire of not
having to ever worry about money again
which is to me a big difference there's
different things yeah yeah so it
definitely impacted my childhood and I
think for a long time part of what drove
me was the desire to kind of reclaim my
family's position and not always having
to just be on the outskirts of the the
world in which they had lived because of
the economic disparity between my family
and their family friends and relatives
and so that was important to me right
it's still important to me right so you
start selling Xerox machines sexiest job
alive yeah Howard Shelton I the two
people that start on the west side of
Manhattan in the Georgia - not - who did
I heard that and I was I said that when
I met him once and I said you know you
and I both sold Xerox copiers I mean
it's it's a good it's a good learning
experience I mean Xerox had an
incredible sales training program and
you know getting the door literally
slammed in your face if you will say
that they get the dorsum in their face
but they don't literally mean the door
it was you know it was a challenging
walking up and down Hulk
knocking on doors selling people copiers
that they really didn't need and you
gotta like get that credit card bill
paid yeah but I'm gonna I was determined
I mean I had no choice and and and doing
it in in the diamond district basically
immersed in or
the docks Jewish culture right which
which is a very different kind of you
know paradigm it was you know it was
funny because they used to make fun of
me I see right you know I grown up and
you know Katonah New York Bedford area
you know sort of this white Watsky girl
that came in knocking on the door and
they used to laugh like they thought it
was really funny they loved me that got
happier from you yeah preppy girl and
they were you know but they they would
give me so much [ __ ] and then and then
ultimately I figured it out like I
figured out the art of negotiating with
them I figured out I listened enough to
figure out what it was and when I
finally would say actually I don't want
to say this copy no more forget it and I
would walk out the door they'd be like
okay well sign and so once I learned how
they dealt in business it made it a lot
easier for me to work with them what was
it that you learned specifically like
what is it about that that was different
specific did that group of men and it
was all men at the time is that they
wanted to feel like they've kind of
broken you like they've gotten as far as
they could to a point where you were
literally willing to walk away and if
they felt like there was just even like
a little glimmer that they could go just
a little farther they would just keep
going and they would continue to refuse
you but once you throw up your hands and
just said screw it I don't care then
they're like okay then you start selling
a lot of copiers I sell a lot of copies
well where does wedding lists come in so
I so you're asking about you know dark
secrets you know earlier before we
started why we're here yeah so when I
was really really young I my husband
probably won't be thrilled that I'm
saying this but you know I got married
very young quickly for about a
five-month stint in the age of 24 25
anger than mine
yeah yeah it started I think I would
need to get starter marriage but anyway
so I I did and two great guy but just
wasn't the right long-term you know
relationship for me but it during that
process of getting married and watching
all of my friends get married I was
constantly looking at all these hideous
bridesmaids dresses and thinking you
know you've got you gotta buy all these
dresses you don't like the color you
don't like the fit you don't have the
money to pay for them and so I started
selling bridesmaids dresses on the side
with a friend of mine we started a
little business called Elizabeth Gregg
and our goal was to solve the problem of
you know dresses that no one liked and
that led me to learning a little bit
about the wedding industry and in my day
job which was with a brokerage firm at
the time Post Xerox I was transferred to
London
and met a woman named Nicole Hindmarch
who was selling wedding gifts in London
through a wedding registry service and I
thought well maybe I could partner with
her to sell bridesmaids dresses and she
quickly told me like they don't use
bridesmaids in the way that the
Americans do but we became friends and I
became intrigued with her business
concept and ultimately over two year
period we kept in touch and then when I
decided I want to go out on my own I
approached her to bring that concept to
the States
mmm so hence began you know the true
kind of entrepreneurial lark that you've
been on ever since and this was like
what like 90 yeah so I was I think I was
in I was in London and you know 95 995
so it was that's it all started around
them yeah it's kind of like AOL era so
you know commerce was like you know
something that people were talking about
but something that people weren't
actually doing that much of like there
was still the trust issue like can I buy
something online and that was a big part
of like you were like way ahead of the
curve with this we were way ahead I
remember my first deck when I went out
to raise capital for the wedding list
that literally said I mean it's so funny
today it's at the convenience of online
purchasing and I would first of all I've
been here you're selling your girl
you're in your mid-20s you're selling
two men a wedding registry concept
online and the answer is word assembly I
mean the guy's eyes would glaze or you
know they had no interest in getting
involved in wedding gifts and everyone
said well I call my secretary who calls
my wife who you know then buys that he
at the time that I was a CEO of sex with
Avenue and then you know and then after
my wife you know signs off she goes to
comes to sex and buys the president and
I thought well okay I love the fan and I
was like you've got to be kidding me
I was like you need me a lot more than I
need you like you need to learn that
this is where we're going but it was
really ahead of its time a little too
hard too far ahead of it right so these
these venture capitalists just couldn't
wrap her heads around shopping online at
that point yeah it was too risky or I
just think that I mean they did and they
ultimately gave us some funding but it
was it was foreign to them and I think
that they kept thinking about wedding
registry as this experience that you
know you need to physically go to the
store and I was saying I think it's more
like a commodity someone knows
what they want to pay for a wedding gift
and so if they can click at $50 or $75
and be done they don't ever want to go
to a store right so I you know look at
women it was an interesting business
coming what was interesting about it
also was it was one of the first true
multi-channel retail business models
multi-channel meaning your your cross
products from various different
retailers yes no meaning multi-channel
meaning that you as a client of the
business or consumer could come to our
store you could shop online you know you
didn't have to we had a catalog so there
we were multiple touchpoints and
historically you either were in the
physical store or starting people we're
starting to creep online but you didn't
have multiple channels working together
to create the best experience for
consumers we take that for granted today
but this is a while ago and this is like
web 1.0 yes you know this is this is
well before the 2008 you know crash of
web 2.0 yes so what did you what did you
learn them that's been instrumental now
how so many things I mean I think one
thing that has served me well this time
around is realizing and I say this to
people who are looking at businesses are
trying to build businesses that you know
you never you have it in you to do what
you need to get done and oftentimes when
you have a good idea people will attach
themselves and make them make you feel
like you need them I'm sure you
experienced this in your life and so I
learned to get I've gotten smarter about
that and trying to really figure out who
could be helpful to me and who just
wants to be attached to my business idea
and then also I think the other big
learning for me with the wedding list
was that you have a choice and investors
and and granted at that time I didn't
have as much of a choice but who
actually supports you financially I mean
you and I were just having a
conversation about another friend with
an investor where if you don't have the
right person they're not aligned with
your interests it's gonna be very very
difficult and I think I was so desperate
to take in the cash at the time that I
made some bad decisions and I chose the
wrong people and they ultimately were
the demise of the business right so you
sell the business to Martha Stewart mhm
and that becomes the that's the first
acquisition of Martha Stewart living
right at the time so then Martha Stewart
becomes your boss what was that like
too bad you don't drink anymore you know
talk about it you know it was it was
difficult well it was difficult for a
variety of reasons not the least of
which was that was the first acquisition
and the entire brand had been built
around Martha and I was the face of the
wedding listen it was very much built
around me and so I we know was getting a
lot of press there was it was that
moment in time where all the dot-coms
were booming and younger people were
being highlighted so that was difficult
I think also she had a chief operating
officer at the time Sharon Patrick and
had me reporting to both Martha and
Sharon so and they didn't agree on
anything so no matter which way I went I
was screwed like I mean someone was
always mad at me and and working for
Martha I mean you know it's I've learned
a lot about leadership and I don't made
tons of mistakes along the way but the
way in which she led people which was
really a fear-based leadership model to
me was something I definitely learned I
didn't want to replicate it because she
just was ruthless she's incredibly
talented but she is also ruthless I
heard that she or I read that she would
call you at 6:01 every day to make sure
that you were still in the office
typically like not necessarily every day
but for sure Friday nights like this
second you started driving to the
Hamptons or you know upstate New York or
wherever you might be going it was like
she literally would call you and ask you
where you were I mean I just couldn't
win I mean I remember the very first
week when I was going through
orientation there this is probably the
beginning when I started to irritate her
so you go into the Martha Stewart
offices and I've been there for many
many years but they had pretzel sticks
oatmeal dyed coke coke and v8 juice like
a totally random assortment of things
and I remember them telling me on my
tour you should drink va cheese because
Martha likes the 80s and I was like what
and so and I got in the first league I
was on some plane with her Isaac do you
really actually drink the ages I like
the ages but this is a long time ago but
but are you telling me I have to drink
v8 used to work for when there was
cranberry juice too and she looked at me
like I was crazy and I said like I'm not
gonna drink v8 juice cuz that's what you
want me to drink that wasn't that was
surprising how did she what was her
reaction I mean she doesn't like it if
you you know I was the person in the
room that when she'd say who picked that
hideous color of light blue and I'd say
Martha you did yesterday remember the
meeting at 4:45 whereas everyone else
would be like oh I'm so sorry Martha
made a bad decision I just wasn't gonna
put up with it so where does that where
is that like fearless compunction come
from that's yeah that's a good you're I
mean you're nothing if not direct like
you're very direct but in a way that
that doesn't alienate like you're like
oh she's just you just call it like you
see it they can alienate some people for
sure I think that I don't know you know
my parents were extremely communicative
we had sort of no [ __ ] in our family
both my mother and father you know if
you asked them a question about
something they would give you a very
direct answer so I was brought up that
way you know so when my kids ask me
questions about life or sex or whatever
it is like I'm gonna just answer the
question as I see fit I'm not gonna make
up some convoluted story to protect them
or to shield them from understanding
what's really going on so I think I was
always encouraged to be direct and I
don't know I think I was really scrappy
I was telling my youngest daughter
Georgie the other day who's pretty short
and I'm pretty short too but I was
really short when I was little just like
she is that some boy was making fun of
my name and he's like your name's Greg a
hood and I just punched him and I broke
my thumb and I don't know there's
something in me that if I don't like it
I'm just gonna tell you how I just
always been that way it's always in that
way I don't punch anyone anymore but
I've been but I am direct well it serves
you in a leadership role for sure right
like you have a vision you're executing
on it you know what you need and what
you want what you don't like and what
you do like and to be able to
communicate that directly and
effectively I would imagine it helps
things get done a little bit more
efficiently I think that being really
politic and kind of dancing around
people so it's interesting I've you know
when I got to LA I always been a tough
place for me to live socially it's just
in a hard place for a lot of reasons and
I think for a moment in time when I
started beautycounter I was pretty like
the least confident secure that I've
been in life for whatever reason I think
it was really humbling to move here to
this town and start all over again and I
was I didn't really feel like my equity
was valued in Los Angeles when I first
moved here and so I was not as direct as
I had been in previous jobs and in life
and I actually think it created a
difficult culture at beautycounter for a
long time which we've been undoing now I
am incredibly direct and I can say it
with kindness and with empathy but in
compassion but to say you let me down or
I don't agree with this or we need to
move in another
I've gotten much more comfortable again
and being that way because I think it's
critically important in all
relationships in life to be direct and I
think in today's marketplace with
building a consumer facing brand or just
in dealings in business people are
craving authenticity and I always say to
people you might like what I'm gonna say
or you might not but you know we're not
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you the
truth at least you can count on that
right so what brought you to Los Angeles
my husband's job and you know Mark had
been offered an opportunity to start a
wealth management business out in the
west coast with his previous firm and
you know we'd been looking at you know
you know New York and I Love New York
it's my hometown but it can be a grind
as you know and we've kind of been
debating what our next step might be and
we thought you know what the hell is try
LA we went now you know you know you
know the typical LA story when you hear
someone gets transferred out there they
take you to shudders you know on a
Tuesday night when the Sun setting and
you look at the ocean and it's warm and
it's you know you know 20 degrees below
zero in new york city it seems pretty
compelling and we decided to move and
we've been here for 11 years now yeah it
is hard to move here though it's a very
alienating city every it's so it's so
diffused that it's it's difficult to
connect with people and to make it says
it doesn't have that vitality in
spontaneity that New York does I mean
New York is very unique in that regard
but most urban centers are concentrated
enough that provide you that it provides
you with some aspect of that but in LA
you really have to work hard and it took
me years living here to like find where
I like to go and where the people are
that I like and where's my community in
my tribe like you have to really
shoulder it yourself whereas in New York
it kind of just it's it just lands on
top of your head I think that LA can be
really really lonely and I think part of
it is to sort of just the giad Geograph
did you got geography of the city it's
so spread out that it's and and you know
I'm so tired of the traffic conversation
because I was in New York last week
twice in the last 10 days and I think
the traffic is insane everywhere but it
is physically really spread out and to
your point it's it's hard to find your
tribe it's been really hard for me to
find my tribe here and I don't think
it's all about the entertainment
industry either I think it's just people
are they're busy they're living their
lives and they're physically spread out
it's just not easy to there's no central
place that you can always bump into
those people you love
right so after wedding list you do a
couple different things you're
consulting on retail brands and then you
run this company best in company I'm not
really sure what that was about what
like I don't even know what that that
did but yeah and you worked for you know
more powerful women you worked for Tommy
Hilfiger's that's wife right what's her
first name Annie right that was another
interesting experience that was that was
that was a brilliance I mean you know
best in company I know you know you say
what have I learned along the way
another thing that I've learned along
the way is when it seems too good to be
true it is too good to be true and I
think when I went to work for I was so
honored to get the call from Tommy I
mean you know I've worked in the retail
and fashion world so for me it was such
a big deal he was and continues to be
such an incredible icon and powerful
businessman and he had they had this
legendary children's clothing brand that
had kind of gone to funked and they were
bringing it back to life and it was an
amazing brand there aren't a lot of
great American brands out there that are
kind of older and I was excited about it
but I think you know they were going
through a time where he was trying to
make the company profitable Suzy was and
they were getting divorced I was caught
in the crosshairs and honestly I don't
think I handled my position as CEO
particularly well I think I was cocky I
think I was a lot it's funny as you get
older how much less cocky you can become
but it's just I think I come off the
wedding list and I probably thought I
was the [ __ ] and I didn't treat her with
the respect that she deserves and she
was challenging to work with but you
know I blew it and I got fired in front
of everybody
yeah messenger with a letter right read
in front of you were having like a staff
meeting or something yeah I remember it
so well maybe you know the person that
messenger buzzes or like said are you
Greg Renfrew I said I am me the CEO of
best in company I am hold on everybody
this give me a second and I open up the
letter and it's basically like you're
out of here Wow I mean it was to say it
was a shock to the system I mean I knew
we weren't getting along particularly
well but that was I'm talking about not
being direct that's the antithesis of
the way that I operate that's like an
analogue text firing yeah
yeah it old-school
it was good I'll give her that she got
me
yeah first sir so let's let's talk about
beautycounter I mean well walk me
through the inspiration for this and
what gave you this idea you know there
wasn't one specific thing but I was
actually last night my friend Lila Rose
was in town from New York visiting and
it was Lila you know Lila had watched in
Inconvenient Truth and became super
passionate about the environmental
health movement and said to me you need
to watch this film you are you know
you're you're loud you're direct you are
connected and I think you should pay
attention to what's going on with the
environment and so I watched and
Inconvenient Truth and for whatever
reason that movie rocked my world it was
just the first time I know it's it's
almost embarrassing to admit this but it
was the first time that I truly paid
attention to the fact that things that I
was doing that we're doing in my daily
life that the my very existence was
doing was creating wreaking havoc on the
earth and so I became focused on the
environmental health movement and
started to really make changes in my
life over the next year or two I also
had a situation where I had a woman who
was taking care of our kids or Phoebe at
the time my oldest who was our nanny I
was working full time running best and
company and at thirty-one she was
diagnosed with a non hpv-related
cervical cancer and within eleven months
she had died and and so I was watching
this young beautiful amazing woman die
in front of me I was watching all these
friends of mine struggle with fertility
issues or giving birth to kids who had
pretty significant health issues they
looked at what was happening the
environment I thought like something's
gone terribly awry and maybe I need to
do something about it and it wasn't
about beauty or Beauty County at the
time it was just how do I start to
become how do I keep myself on what's
actually going on that's there so that
can be a vocal point right for change
and there's kind of this epiphany moment
when you're using products on your kids
thinking they're because they're they
have the words natural lawn I think
you're using the right brand or whatever
and then looking at the ingredients
label and doing a little research and
realizing that the
the the gap between what you're being
told or sold and the truth is pretty
fast you know I thought I was that has
that Whole Foods shopper I was the mom
that was going to local farm stands as
eating organic I mean I thought I was
doing all the right things I gotten rid
of all our plastic I was washing my
floors with water and vinegar and then I
was looking at this and my kids had two
kids in the tub and it was a natural
foaming oatmeal body wash from a leading
drugstore brand and I thought it mean it
looks like oatmeal it smelled like
oatmeal kind of to me and then someone
told me about the Environmental Working
Group skin deep database and I took a
look at it and I was like holy [ __ ] it
was like eight out of nine for toxicity
and I was pretty outraged so that really
was another trigger point for me that's
when I started switching all of my
family's products but the one thing that
I couldn't find for myself was just I
couldn't find any skincare at cosmetics
that I wanted to use and there just
wasn't anything out there and and the
more that I learned the more that I
realized that we had laws that were
incredibly outdated the more I realized
that there were harmful chemicals in our
products I I wanted to do something
about it which is really why I started
the company right yeah that realization
and then the leap to like I'm gonna
create a company around this like that's
a that's a jump yeah well you know it's
a journey it was looking for your next
thing at that time and not well yeah no
I mean I think that you know I think all
of this happened over a three you know
from from start you know watching a new
community to when I actually started to
focus on beautycounter was over the
course of about four years and it wasn't
you know iterative process of trying to
figure out what I wanted to do with my
life what I felt was important and how
did I protect everyone I loved and when
I moved to Los Angeles I spent about 10
months consulting for Jessica Alba prior
to the launch of the honest company and
so I was I was looking at it from a
personal standpoint having experienced
all the things I did prior to moving to
LA and then on a professional standpoint
looking at the entire marketplace of
products and thinking well they're you
know we're well served in certain areas
but in in personal care products and
cosmetics no one's doing anything and so
you know it took me a while to figure it
out and at some point yes I did just say
I think I want to start a business
we'll bring actually was supposed to be
safe make up and then I was like wait I
can put safer makeup on top of toxic
skincare so then I went back and started
thinking about it and ultimately that's
when the idea for beauty came again and
you're like the perfect person to do
this right with all the retail
experience and early you know internet
web experience direct-to-consumer and
and being involved with honest at its
gestation point understanding kind of
that that health and beauty space a
little bit yeah you know we I wasn't
actually you know honest had not started
when I when I was when I left when when
Jessica and I decided to part ways it
was still conceptual it was really
focused on you know baby when and I knew
that world the reason why I was I was
hired by her as I understood baby
because I was running a children's
clothing company before and she had
originally wanted to start children's
clothing organic children's clothing
line and so I think I where I was the
perfect person I was a perfect person
for a couple of reasons one when I when
I when I care about something I care
about it deeply and I really really have
no problem walking out to phone saying
like please don't put that on your body
like I care I mean I don't I'm so tired
of hearing people tell me that they're
sick I'm sure you are too we know way
too many people who are sick and so I am
the perfect person because I wasn't
gonna take no for an answer and I care
so deeply about this issue that I was
gonna I was determined to take it all
the way right I consider myself to be
somebody who's fairly up to speed on
environmental issues and and certainly
I'm the first to say that you know
governmental regulatory bodies are not
necessarily looking out for your best
interest but even I was shocked when we
were talking you know you were telling
me last year about the extent to which
you know the the FDA is just this paper
tiger when it comes to protecting people
on the cosmetic and and kind of skin
care front yeah I mean I think that you
know someone was asked me the other day
why people worry why they feel that they
feel safe why do people feel safe in the
United States in terms of the products
on the shelves and I was saying that in
the food industry if there are two
things I think that are different about
skincare and cosmetics and that and just
for clarity purposes I know you have a
lot of men that listen to
you talk about things it's this isn't
red lipstick this is deodorant sunscreen
body look anything that we're putting on
our bodies any of those things I think
that two things are different when you
when you eat something that's really bad
for your body you typically get sick you
know you're right you feel it where a
direct reaction right whereas if you're
putting on sunscreen or body lotion you
could go your whole life and you would
never necessarily know that it was
harmful to your health and then the
second thing is I mean yes if you have
an allergic reaction but in the absence
of allergic reactions people would just
continue to put stuff on their body they
wouldn't know about it and I think the
second thing that's different is that
the FDA in the food industry has the
ability to recall product when it's
known to be harmful to health if there's
a salmonella outbreak or whatever it is
they can immediately pull it from the
shelves but what people don't realize in
the United States is that when it comes
to skincare and cosmetics they do not
have the ability to recall product they
can suggest but they cannot take action
that is shocking to me so play that out
like there's a pro there's a cosmetic
product or some you know skin lotion
that's on the shelves at every store and
it's got proven toxic chemicals that
have been established to link directly
to some kind of poor health condition
and the FDA is absolutely powerless to
compel the industry to remove it correct
so there are a couple things that are
not happening with the FDA first and
foremost we are not screening chemicals
for safety before we put them into the
products that we use also shocking yeah
so less than 10% of the 85,000 chemicals
that have been introduced into commerce
have been tested for safety and about
10,000 of those are commonly used in
personal care products so let's just say
a solid nine thousand plus have never
been tested for safety on human or
environmental health then you combine
that with the lack of regulation where
people can claim natural pure botanical
whatever they want in skincare and
cosmetics and there's no regulation so
for example a year or two ago there was
an article about aloe based products
they tested 38 aloe based products
across departments that department
stores and drugstores and they found
that not a single one of them had one
little drop of aloe in them and then you
know the third type of scenario is the
scenario and an example would be
Brazilian Blowout or there's one called
when haircare where they've had over
20,000 complaints of hair loss permanent
hair loss for children and
women and yet they were so yeah and it's
still on the shelves and same with
Brazilian Blowout we're the people who
are administering that hair
straightening treatment we're getting
incredibly sick but they can't do
anything about it because I had over 40%
formaldehyde and think about you're
heating up formaldehyde and blowing it
all over and everyone's breathing it in
the FDA can't do anything about it and
that's why at beauty counter we're so
focused on our advocacy efforts because
we need to update these these outdated
laws how did we get to this point you
know what this I mean look I think there
are a number of things I think first of
all there was a brief moment of time in
1938 when the Federal Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act passed where Americans were
protected but that was prior to you know
these 85,000 chemicals coming into
commerce post-world war ii and so a lot
of the leading companies that are
manufacturing products a lot of large
conglomerates started making these
products when they probably you know
thought they were totally safe why
wouldn't they have thought they were
safe and now I think that the challenge
becomes you know how do you undo this
and how do you when you're sitting with
relentless capital markets and you know
you take your share price down at you
know or whatever you do the right thing
and you take a massive hit I think
people are scared to change and so and I
think that we haven't updated major of
federal law since 1938 I mean it's been
over 80 years so governing law in this
that kind of covers this entire
landscape is one law that was passed in
nineteen thirty one and a half pages of
legislation that govern an eighty
billion dollar industry that still allow
for chemicals of concern that are known
to be caused that cause cancer link to
endocrine disruption all those things
neurotoxicity those chemicals are in our
products and the government has not
taken action on the federal level so a
big part of your mission and why you
founded this company is this advocacy
piece of getting these laws changed and
and part of that has been you going to
Washington DC and banging on doors to
get people to pay attention to this
right there's a new bill that you're
you're you know trying to advocate for
for vote at that but this has been going
on for a year likes institute the 2015
or something like that so we when we
launched you know from the very
beginning I said
you know there are three things that we
need to do that are really important we
need to educate because we knew that
less than 20% of Americans had any idea
that there are chemicals of concern and
I look I've always said this we needed
no one needed another beauty brand I
mean I'm not even a beauty yeah I was
never even Beauty person like I never
even it wasn't my thing but I what we
needed to create a movement for better
cleaner safer products for everyone and
so education has always been a core
component of our business and using
commerce as an engine for change has
also been a core component cuz I do
think that consumer brands can move
markets faster than legislated like
legislative reform will ever happen on
that on the advocacy side you know we
started from right out of the gate when
I was raising capital I said to all of
our investors we're gonna take this all
the way to Washington you need to be
comfortable with that and we started
immediately the minute we had any scale
and you know 2013 we started to go out
there and talk about it and we started
on the state and federal level and now
we do this in Canada as well I didn't
say this earlier but not only have we
not updated the laws since 1938 the EU
banned or restricted depending on the
chemical about 1,400 ingredients well
over a decade ago when I started
beautycounter we had 11 to their 1,400
and now we're up to a whopping 30 so we
had to get out there and pound the
pavement in Washington we needed to let
them know that it's time to change and
and walk me through the experience of
sitting down with these senators and
congressmen said the one thing mark did
say is he's like ask Greg about what's
his name Lamar Alexander yeah it wasn't
Lamar Alexander but it was someone from
his office I walked in and the guy said
oh you know you effing Californians with
your vaccinations and you know you're
you know you won't vaccinate your kids
and you're you know high and mighty and
your prop 65 and I said listen dude I
did and I was like listen calm down in
New York and I look at Greg I the first
thing I think is communists totally that
is me if they're into yeah so I was like
listen I'm from New York City so let's
let's start over again but yeah I mean I
think at the end of the day you know
that we're there total and complete
disconnect is between and it's not even
a Republican Democratic side of things
it's just it's it's on state preemption
who gets to MIT to who is the holy
grails the f
years of the state you know if you look
at California which is taken pretty
significant health protective measures
they're gonna say no the federal
government is not the holy grill we're
gonna determine what things are or are
not safe and and then on the other side
of it the argument is no the FDA has to
be the holy grail for research and we
need to decide it you know what isn't is
not safe and Feinstein's office with
said well to hell with that we're not
gonna we're not gonna go backwards and
the other offices said well great well
we're not gonna do it unless the FDA has
the ultimate power so that's where we've
kind of come to a standstill but it was
an interesting meeting and and I you
know I think the talk about being direct
I think the funny thing about Washington
it's always like oh thank you so much
for that mr. senator thank you so much
mrs. senator I think what you're Sid was
so unbelievable meanwhile they hate each
other and they talk to each other as if
they're like in a super formal language
mr. and mrs. I mean the whole thing
cracks me up because you know you walk
out of the room and they like want to
kill each other and everything's about
compromise and everything's about who
you know who negotiated harder against
one another and I'm kind of like why
don't we just come up with a solution
and get stuff done right but God there's
bipartisan support for this percent
right like everybody wants our our
skincare products to be safe regardless
of where you fall on the political
spectrum however we are you know we are
dealing with a very you know we're in
the era of Trump and anti regulations so
that makes it obviously much more
difficult you know I know actually yes
yes he is anti regulation I don't think
that Trump is necessarily made it any
more difficult I think it's been
difficult for a really long time what's
been interesting for me one of the
things has been so cool about
beautycounter for me is that I've gotten
to spend a lot of time with a lot of
people around the country and and been
able to hear things from different
perspectives and the one of the things I
think I'm most proud of with
beautycounter is the fact that you have
people who literally live on polar
opposite ends of the spectrum when it
comes to their political views but
they're able to join forces and get
behind a movement that they believe in
and to your point a moment ago I there
is not a single person in the United
States of America that has not been
drugged you know directly or indirectly
touched by the health issues we face as
a nation today and so that is one thing
we can all agree on and I think everyone
on both sides of the aisle will also
agree that we do need cosmetic reform
it's the it's the tactics that it's
becoming more challenging but everyone
knows it needs to change there
is there is this weird trust though that
when I go to the store and I pull
something off the shelf and buy it I am
presuming that it's then you know vetted
and that it's safe and to realize like
well that's not necessarily the case is
quite an eye-opener and I do think that
that most people either are not aware of
that it doesn't occur to them or they
don't even think about like it's not
part of the calculus when they're
deciding which brands are gonna they're
gonna buy I mean it that's changing
obviously in no small parts of what
you're doing but like that's the first
step right getting people to kind of
shock them out of that that sense of
safety it's it's something that we work
on every day and in trying to balance
one of the things I always say to
everyone that works with us is our goal
is not to shame companies or individuals
for the choices that have been made all
we can do is create a better path
forward and our job is to show them the
way and to help people make more
informed choices on behalf of their
families and you know and it's it's look
the waters are murky and it's
complicated and people don't have a lot
of time and I always you know I always
say to people if you're gonna go
shopping just at least shop
fragrance-free
like so many of the most offensive
chemicals are found in the fragrances so
just go for a fragrance for your line
just to start that'll help less is more
and you know and look for you know
things like parabens and things on the
label there are certain ingredients we
have something called a never list and
we always ask people to print it out and
go shop the market with it because again
I of course I'm trying to build a
business that's successful and a
movement but the the you know success
for me is how did we change the entire
industry not how do we sell more beauty
counter products because we're only one
solution and we're not accessible to
everyone financially or just physically
not everyone gets to us so how do we
make sure that everyone's being
protected and how do we help people shop
the market when they're out there right
the bill that you were really getting
behind is the personal care products
safety right and there's this newer bill
called the natural cosmetics act my read
of that though is that that's much more
of a labeling initiative that's not it's
not really about getting rid of the
toxins in the products themselves it's
just about what shows up on the label to
apprise the consumer of what's in it
correct there are totally different
things the the the natural label
labeling is important because I said as
I said earlier you don't people can say
they're natural
and they're not at all and so that's
just completely misleading so really
trying to define what you know isn't is
not natural we get a lot we get behind a
lot of different things we really focus
on when Hawaii was space you know focus
on sunscreen and safer sunscreen because
you know oxybenzone is you know these
things are killing the coral reef so we
try to get involved in a lot of things
the personal care product Safety Act was
that was that first sort of bipartisan
bill you know that was really trying to
do a couple of things which is to screen
ingredients for safety prior to them
being put in products on the shelves and
to give the FDA the ability to recall
product when they know that its harm for
the health and that those were the two
key tenets of that that bill and we are
still hopeful that we'll pass through
are there big lobbying efforts on behalf
of these global brands that are trying
to prevent this from of course of course
you know there's the there's a whole
lobbying the the cosmetics industry has
a whole lobbying that's sort of like a
self I mean it's it's almost self
regulated and so that's always
interesting when you when you go in
there and they and they talk about well
this is all these things are totally
safe and you know that they're not some
of the bigger companies have taken
action I think those that understand
that it is time for change they whether
they whether they're doing it behind the
scenes reluctantly or not there are
companies that are trying to move the
needle I think where the bigger
companies have been more focused on
they're more focused on sustainability
they know that the consumer is demanding
them to be sustainable and packaging
carbon footprint and I think they've
made some of the big companies have made
huge strides there they've been less
aggressive on the ingredients and part
of it is and you know people would say
not to use this example but I think it's
a good one if I were to to be running
coca-cola today and someone said okay
create healthy cook I want it to taste
exactly the same I want it to sparkle in
the same way in my mouth or whatever
good luck making that with safe
ingredients right um it's just not you
know I don't know how they do that it's
the same thing in cosmetics you know a
scent a texture all those things are
really ingredient dependent it's not
easy for them to switch out ingredients
so they tend to then focus their efforts
on sustainability as opposed to
ingredients right I mean it's it's one
thing when you're talking about
deodorant or toothpaste but the typical
customer consumer that goes into you
know the Sephora's of the world
like they're not thinking about they're
not thinking about toxicity at all
they're just like oh I like that color
yeah exactly right most people I mean I
mean increasing the younger generation
obviously people are more aware now than
they were before and you know Sephora
has taken a position on clean which I
appreciate it's I think that most people
are I want to look younger I want to I
don't want to have acne I want to look
sexy I want to feel beautiful they're
not they're not worried about it I don't
want to smell I don't want like I don't
like it sunburn I mean these are these
are things that people are thinking
about and they're not thinking oh gosh I
hope I don't get cancer from this
ingredient and look I don't know it's I
always say to everyone I don't mean to
be an alarmist it's not that I know that
moment in time when a cell goes from
being healthy to unhealthy and I'm not
saying that if you use a toxic lotion
that you're inevitably gonna get sick
but we do know that the you know the
these chemicals you know combined you
know you know we put we can put hundreds
of chemicals on our bodies before we
even walk out of the bathroom in the
morning and people aren't thinking about
that and the cumulative impact of small
doses of toxic chemicals we don't know
exactly
we know it's linked to these issues we
don't know exactly what things right
triggers there's there's the eventual
health outcome of long-term persistent
use but there's also the environmental
impact of the manufacturing of these
things so talk a little bit about that
like what goes on behind the scenes at a
typical conventional you know cosmetics
company in the processing of these
products like what is the runoff what
you know what happens in the environment
as a result of I think we're I think
it's not so much the processing in terms
of actually what happens in the plant in
terms of moving through the systems that
you know batch things and heat things
and move them where I think that you see
the environmental impact of if the
cosmetics industry in general is in a
couple of ways and I think like anything
else when you're using carful chemicals
they pollute the waterways when you when
you actually go to get rid of your
products you know they're considered to
be toxic I mean it's amazing you have
toxic waste you know you're going to go
throw things away so there I'll put it
on my skin but you can't put it in the
garbage
it's an
it's an it's considered hazardous
materials I mean it's unbelievable I
mean that there there I mean let me
Marilyn lies the contradiction we are
putting in we are throwing things away
under hazardous material nomenclature
and yet we're actually a lot to put it
on our body so I think that's the crazy
thing but I do think that what we look
at right now you know as a company when
we look at supply chain is obviously we
look at we're looking very much at our
carbon footprint our uses of materials
and packaging the recyclability which is
super challenging in the beauty industry
and trying to use better better things
and trying to work with you know
institutions to find safer alternatives
for the for their health of the earth a
lot of plastic is used in cosmetics and
we've been trying to move away from that
as as our many but I do think it's also
for us you know we're what's called a B
corporation people plan a profit we have
been since the beginning we have to put
an emphasis all three of those pillars
it's not just it has to be triple bottom
line and so when we look at the supply
chain now we look at you know human
rights issues we look at our people
being paid a fair wage you know we've
just recently taken on mica as a major
initiative that's a very dirty secret of
the beauty industry so most of the mica
is being you know mined with illegal or
forced label or child labour in India
and Japan and China and places like that
and so one of the things that we're
really focused on is is taking the
consumer through this journey of how we
actually create systemic change in these
communities that desperately need the
jobs because they need to put food on
the table but they're putting people who
are not getting pay it's it's a it's a
very sketchy situation out there and
we're really we've just our team just
got back last week from India where
we're actually gonna hope to be the
first company actually audit all of our
minds and then do something about this
issue and it's not just cosmetics it's
also automotive and electronics but we
need to change this situation so we look
at that is like how does it impact or
you know palm oil and you know is it
sustainably harvest and what are we
doing that those are all the things that
we look at every single day it's
exhausting yeah conditions all of that I
think it's an amazing opportunity you
know on the on the education tip like to
illuminate what actually goes on and and
and to the extent that you can do that
completely transparently is an amazing
service but I think it also is smart
sense because it engenders you know
loyalty and Trust in your in your
customers I think it does I think that
one of the things that is difficult
though is that people don't understand
the complexity of it and I certainly
wouldn't have I certainly didn't before
I started to build this business but you
know it's everything from how do you
create the performance expectations of
the consumer because at the end of day
if you're not meeting her or his
expectations they won't use the product
if you take a deodorant and you feel
like you still smelled an hour later or
whatever you're not gonna use that
deodorant anymore so that's really
important so we have to do that we have
to look at the ingredients and make sure
that they are you know not you know that
we've taken a couple thousand
ingredients and said these are these are
on our restricted list we have to make
sure they're not there we're testing for
trace contaminants trace heavy metals
then you get to the packaging you make
sure it actually works with the formula
and then is not leaching toxic chemicals
back into the products and then you've
got to look up and down the supply chain
what is the carbon you know footprint
what is the impact of this how are
people being treated how are where are
those ingredients coming from around the
world I mean it's it's a full-on job and
we've just begun to scratch the surface
of what we can do but I do think we you
know we talk about it internally you
can't just say well we're gonna reduce
secondary cartons we did that this year
and we'll save them you know a million
you know a million less secondary
cartons will go out but it's like how do
you actually get to the root of the
problem and change the world right and
these things are infinitely more
complicated than incredibly new laws
incredibly and so sometimes I think that
consumers can be unforgiving because
they're also being misled by companies
they're saying that they're perfectly
pure they're this and that they just
don't they don't know it and it's not
their fault I didn't either
yeah I would imagine it's the kind of
thing like more you learn about it the
more you realize how difficult it is to
do it right you know and the the sort of
average modestly informed consumer has a
very binary perspective like well just
don't do it you know like don't do that
thing well if we don't do that then this
happens in this hat you know like to in
order to like create a viable business
that you can grow to scale you're gonna
have these compromises and I'm sure
there's a lot you know like do we do
this do we not do this it's gotta be
really difficult we've focused on a
couple of things since the beginning
first and foremost our platform our
primary platform is is this ingredient
safe for human health
and we're less focus on source we're
about 85% natural but we do use some
man-made ingredients that we think are
safe or help them and that was a
position we took and we do believe that
performance is critically important and
and we do try to what we've said all
along is that it's about progress not
perfection we're not perfect but what
you can count on this we're going to
tell you the truth we can tell you
exactly what we're putting in our
products you can make an informed choice
and we're not going to do what a lot of
companies do for example you know
sometimes people criticize us because we
use preservatives and preservatives are
toxic and by you know nature they're
they're meant to kill right but you
don't want mold and bacteria growing on
your skin either and so there's a
balance there but you know they'll say
oh well that company's preservative free
and I'll say no they just they just know
the loopholes and one of the loopholes
is that you can take you can pre
preserve raw materials and then extract
them and then not have to claim
preservatives even though the
preservatives are in there and these are
the little tricks of the trade so we're
trying to say look we're being
incredibly upfront and we're gonna take
you along this journey as we make things
better and we're hoping that all these
companies follow our lead and you know
you you know that we're the real deal I
mean that's all that's all that we can
do what are some of the other dirty
little secrets that people don't know
well I do think fragrance is a really
big issue because people have no idea
that most of the or many of the most
effective offensive chemicals like
salads salads are also found in you know
vinyl shower curtains in that new car
smell you have but those things that
bind that on to your skin that scent
onto your skin are really really bad
endocrine disrupting chemicals they
they're they so closely mimic the body's
natural systems that the body doesn't
know to reject them and so I think that
you know people don't realize that under
international IP law that you don't have
to claim any of the ingredients in your
fragrance because it's considered
proprietary and that's one big one that
I think that people don't know I think
also people don't know that there you
can say that their formaldehyde free but
there are you know in certain
combinations there there it can present
in other ways and so you know they don't
they don't know any of these things but
but look I don't I don't my goal is not
to scare people what I would I do hope
is that people you know will use
resources available to them like the
Environmental Working Group has
something called the skin deep database
or they can go to beauty counter com2
print out or never list just look at
those this few those few chemicals and
things that you really don't want to
just make sure they're not in your
products right so one of the
cornerstones of your whole thing is this
never list right which is a list of how
many things are on it now like I mean
the one that's public-facing yeah I mean
there's about 2000 things it'll never
find their way at your products and then
the other thing is I mean your greatest
asset and and I'm I'm sure you know an
incredible like Archimedes lover on the
education and advocacy front is all of
your independent contractors like you
made a specific decision about this
business plan about how you wanted to
empower other women to beat up basically
the you're the face of the company but
they're kind of the secondary face of
the company to sell these products but
there's something cool about having this
army of people that are passionate about
what you do and the products that you
guys create who can then also descend on
their local governments or come to
Washington to push for this kind of
change when I started beautycounter I
really wanted to create a movement and
the only way to power a movement is
through people and I also knew that in
the beauty industry specifically but but
we're seeing it happen I mean Barney's
just you know announced that they were
closing that these department stores
were going to go Barney's closing Wow
done over yep and I think it's a sign of
the times which is that most consumers
today are wanting to build direct
relationships with brands we knew that
we had a story to tell and it was a
story that was best told
person-to-person whether that happens
physically or digitally it doesn't
matter but we needed to tell the story
of the need for safer ingredients and
what was really going on in our industry
and so we knew that going to department
stores in that old-school way of doing
business wasn't gonna work for us and a
friend of mine said have you considered
you know using independent consultants I
knew nothing about I think my original
answer was like hell no yeah I don't
know that business I come out of the
retail world but when I started to look
at it I thought this is amazing if you
think about things that have changed no
Mothers Against Drunk Driving or people
advocating for you know no smoking on
airplanes or seatbelts and these are
things that have been powered by women
and women when they care about an issue
can really make a lot of noise and
actually can affect change and
it just happened to be a moment in time
where we had a proposition that was
valuable to women and and and also an
opportunity for them to create to gain
financial independence or at least to be
an equal partner to their spouse or
partner and I think that's been the true
unbelievable silver lining of
beautycounter for me is getting to know
tens of thousands of women empowering
them economically and watching them
thrive through and through being able to
be educators in their communities to be
able to sell products that they believe
in to be able to turn to their husband
or partner and say hey I've got dinner
tonight or we can't afford this private
school education or go back to school
shopping comfortably for the first time
in years and and and then take that one
step farther to say and I'm also
changing the laws and I'm out there on
the state and federal level marching
side by side with people who care about
this issue and I'm gonna leave a legacy
for you know many generations to come
that's been a really powerful
proposition and probably the best thing
that we've done to date how many are
there now we currently have a 45,000
women men so how did you do that I mean
you've grown this thing as far as I can
tell without like any advertising also
right it's just
how did this happen you know I think
that people care about things that
matter right now there's a purpose to it
and I think that there are so many
people wanting to get behind something
that's bigger than they are individually
and you know we literally I mean it's
sort of the way I started selling that
means cleaning houses on Nantucket I
cold called every single real estate
broker on Nantucket and asked them if
they'd give me a chance and when I
started beautycounter I literally went
to cities with myself and a couple of
teammates and I literally got up and
went to tell him what I was doing I
would tell them what I had learned I
told them why I thought it was important
for themselves in their house and ask
them to join me and I always asked
everyone to join me whether that means
you're just texting your member of
Congress you're buying a product or
you're selling product with us we want
you to be part of our movement and we
think that it's important so I literally
organically went out and just talked to
his mate thought was I could who was the
first person that you got there well you
know the first the first person that
began to sell the product was a woman in
Fall River Massachusetts who had worked
previously with my partner Gina and but
it was a lot of his my friends it was
like my stepsister my college roommate
you know like in the beginning it was
just people I knew that
that either wanted to earn some money
needed to earn some money or just cared
so deeply about this issue the ones that
are the most successful are both they're
encouraged by being part of business and
they also care deeply about this issue
there is a weird I mean this is what is
the difference between this and like the
MLM you know like when we when you say
MLM are you looking for some of the
bigger MLM is out there there's always
kind of like a weird like what is that
really like the word pyramid scheme gets
thrown around and I don't think that's
quite fair there's a lot of you know
fantastic successful MLM companies out
there that are hardly pyramid schemes
but I think that what you're doing is it
has similarities to that but it's it's
yeah you know it's funny because when I
said to earlier that my immediate
reaction to independent consultants was
hell no I had that very negative bias
against the MLM or specifically the
network marketing side of it you know if
you look at the business of
direct-to-consumer through independent
consultants on one end of the spectrum
you have a company back let's just go
back 20 years you had a company like
Avon that really only paid people on the
sale of product and that was how you
made your money either sold or you
didn't and then even other companies
like Amway that wasn't about the product
it was all about the business
opportunity and I think what gave people
a negative feeling about the industry
was that for me to say hey rich if you
give me $500 I'm going to show you how
to make 5,000 a it rich quick absolutely
and I think that for us I you know when
I thought about selling through
independent consultants I wanted to do
things differently for two reasons one I
didn't I didn't want there to be that
negative bias so we have moments where
people say that but at the end of the
day we are in the business of educating
and selling product and yes you can
build a team and you can make money off
of a team up to a few people beneath you
in the exact same way that it happens in
a corporation that the CEO of Goldman
Sachs is going to be making money on the
efforts of the other people but they're
primarily spent you know paid on their
own on their own success or lack thereof
that's the way that we've set this up
but I think it's always been about
selling product because that's you know
and in retailing which we always we
always say we're a direct retail model
is the exchange of goods whether it
happens in a physical store through
people but I think also you know in
today's market you have to meet the
consumer where he or she wants to shop
and so for us from day one it was always
we have an independent e-commerce
business we have our independent
consultants who are our backbone we now
have retail stores we've sold through
retail partnerships so we always felt
that to move away from whatever that
pyramid thing was and moved into where
the world has gone today we needed to
empower these people but also help them
by creating an ecosystem they made sense
for the consumer and it's worked really
well yeah so you're firing on all of
those cylinders now the skeezy thing
with the MLM stuff comes in you know on
the shoulders of that kind of
get-rich-quick idea where it's all about
like building this team because that's
where you make your money it's all it's
all about the money
zones were more about the money it's
always about they're always like I'm an
educator I'm like I know but you could
also sell some product I think at the
end of the day that you're absolutely
right I think it's it's the selling an
opportunity versus selling product for
us it's always been about the product
was the solution to the problem because
again we could have just been a
nonprofit organization and but if we had
been that we would have told you all the
problems of the world but we would not
have provided you with the solution and
so we really wanted to create a consumer
facing brand that was focused on the
solution powered by people and I do
think that I will say this you know one
of things that disappoints me
consistently around this business model
or the sort of negative bias thoughts
that people have about it is that 99%
these companies are great honest upfront
upstanding citizens of the of the
corporate world and you know somehow we
don't punish the banks even though
they've done tons of things that are
super corrupt and I think at the end of
the day most I would say average middle
and upper middle income Americans are
struggling to make ends meet right now
and to the extent that I can help you
know create a platform upon which women
and men can be you know home with kids
who are sick or be able to be present
with their children or care for people
who elderly who are sick or have a side
gig because they're you know they're
back in the day but I would love that
side gig you know when I had that credit
card debt and I had to go find a new job
and I think that if we would get more
behind applauding people for taking
initiative to help support their
families and worry less about what old
companies did at one point in time I
think that the country would be a better
place yeah the companies that have
adopted that model they sort of stay in
that
and if you're a retail based business
you kind of go retail vent online but
you were you you're you're doing all of
these business models at once it's
interesting now how many retail stores
do you have so we don't have many right
now we have one in New York we're
opening one in Los Angeles we have one
in Denver we have and then we've got
pop-up so we have a pop-up right now in
Boston we had pop-up on and well we've
had one on Nantucket for a couple of
years we've done pop-ups and outside of
Manhattan and we're going to be doing
more of them because what we found is
it's interesting because we all live on
our phones but everyone is searching for
community and purpose and and what's
been amazing about these stores whether
they're pop-up or long-term ones is they
become a community center for our
clients our consultants it's the
community at large of beauty counter and
people gather and they gather and they
have fun trying and playing with product
they they sell product they they talk to
people about the business and they just
have fun with one another and people
move to new cities and they go to find
beautycounter in Denver and all sudden
they have a home and they've got a place
to go and that's been amazing so I think
I think retail is gonna play in the in
the future an incredibly important part
and it's incredibly supportive of our
consultant network as well
I saw the one in Denver when I was there
I didn't I sent market picture I was
running and I ran by and then we happen
to be in New York when you were at your
store in in lower Manhattan and we
popped in and it was it was like a
cocktail party yeah yeah well you know I
think it's nice I think one of the
things that's been really fun for me
in beauty building beautycounter is
having the opportunity to connect with
these women and to meet them and to get
to know them and when I end up in a city
they'll come out and they'll come out to
say thank you you know it's it's funny
because they will come out for a
cocktail or they'll come out for a green
juice or they'll come in the morning
they'll come at night they'll drive for
many hours and what they often will say
is I just thank you for allowing me to
be part of a community that's that's
moving the needle and thank you for
helping me take care of my family and
often times more times than not the
women who are part of our community have
been touched some some way with the
health side of it and you know I
remember a woman who was in Washington
with me a few years ago said I may have
stage four breast cancer and I may or
may not you know overcome this battle I
probably won't but I know that it will
not be all for naught that I will
have done something important and that
my children will be proud of me for
fighting for laws that protect them in
the future and that's that's something
that's incredibly powerful right like
it's not just a side hustle like it's
it's it's infusing their lives with
purpose that kind of extends beyond
their own you know bank account
absolutely and and but you know it's
also okay we women especially we women
need to tell each other it's also okay
to make money because at the end of the
day we all have bills to pay and money
does not fall off of trees and what I
found that's been super cool is the
shift in the relationships you know
partner to partner spouse to spouse when
two people are earning an income and two
people can say hey let's do this
together as a team and not one person
holding all the you know the purse
strings and the power in the
relationship that the shift in dynamics
between husband and wife or partners
when both of you are contributing even
if it's ones a lot more than the other
it still allows you to have this
conversations hey let's do this together
and I think that you know partnership we
all know marriage is difficult I reminds
perfect of course my husband if you ask
my mother-in-law my husband Mark is
perfect but you know marriage is
difficult but if you're doing it and you
know together as a team it makes it a
hell of a lot easier and I think that's
the thing that's been super cool for me
to watch is women who've said hey my
husband was not into this at all but wow
we were actually able to get my daughter
to summer camp and thank you so much for
that gift for both of us and then you
hear the husband saying wow I see a
spring in her step I haven't seen for
years she feels like she's part of
meaningful change thank you so much
that's awesome let's talk about you as a
CEO okay we've established that you're
very direct listen I mean I think it's
it's one thing to start like oh I'm
gonna start a natural skincare line or
cosmetic line there are lots of kind of
little boutique e type brands out there
but it's it's it's another thing all
together to achieve this at scale right
which is what you're going for and what
you've achieved and you know just
walking the halls of your your office
like you know how many people working
out I mean you're angry about two
hundred and sixty or seventy you know
it's a you're shouldering a huge amount
of responsibility and I would imagine
you probably spend a little you know a
fair amount of time thinking about
you know how you communicate to the
world as a woman CEO and what that means
and the kind of downstream impact of
whatever comes out of your mouth or how
you behave on you know the next
generation of future female executives
and entrepreneurs I think that well
first of all I think it's an honor and a
privilege to build a lead an
organization and that's not lost on me I
mean I think that you to be a successful
CEO in my opinion in today's world you
have to have a relatively high level of
humility you have to know that you were
there to serve I do believe very
strongly in servant leadership I do
believe I'm there to serve them and it's
not about me it's about them and how I
went on your website the beautycounter
website I couldn't find a picture right
now I know it's because like even if you
know our story or our mission and and
and there's a very conscious there was a
very conscious decision to not you know
have your bio or make it about you yeah
I don't think it's about me I do think
it's about working I am an ordinary
person who's able to do extraordinary
work when I work side-by-side with with
you know tens of thousands of people and
I think we're all ordinary but we can do
great things together and I think that
as a woman I think you know one of the
things that I've been talking about a
lot lately
even with my friends over dinner or out
in public places it's just that we've
got to do a better job of supporting one
another as women and the choices we make
and and not assuming that that because
you are a CEO or that you're a powerful
business person that you're that you're
a [ __ ] or that you're tough like with
that word you know I it's hard because
you want to be liked as a woman you want
to be liked but but yet if you are
trying to please everyone all the time
you you're not gonna be a really strong
leader but then often times if you're
strongly or you're considered to be but
you're tough in a way that a man would
be powerful and strong and I've been
trying to figure out that and how I
balance that for myself both both in my
social like life and in my professional
life and you know it's interesting when
I when I feel that I'm most effective as
a leader is when I'm the most
transparent and vulnerable both to our
community at large but also to our
corporate team to say look like I'm
going there after this and we know where
it's the end of the year and people are
exhausted and stress and I don't think
it's I'm not sure everyone in the
corporate office is really happy today
like I don't think that they are but bit
acknowledging that and acknowledging
look I'm trying to balance a husband
three children leading all of you I
don't get it all the you know right all
the time but I'm doing my best and I
think we need more women out there that
are telling the true story which is you
can have it all just not in the same day
and there's a lot of pressure on us to
be perfect all the time so we know what
gives and hey why don't you give like
cut me a little slack and some support
in my decision to work or in the same
way that I might support your decision
not to work I don't know if that makes
sense but it's there's a lot of chatter
out there about women being leaders and
you know I think this is a moment that
we need to take advantage of but we need
to support one another right so what is
the temperature of that support right
now like I've heard you talk about the
kind of competitiveness amongst women
that can be counterproductive
is that fair like I don't a hundred
percent I mean I I do think that there
are there are women there are a lot of
wonderful things that women will do for
them one another but what I have found
to be true in general gross
generalization is that many of the most
powerful women are not really Pro women
women so you have to find the ones that
genuinely want to support your in your
effort to change the world and I think
that they are you know I always say I
spent a lot of time on panels and in
conferences with women who are kind of
just men in skirts they're not able
they're trying to project this perfect
polished I look beautiful act beautiful
I'm super smart and I just don't think
that's what women are craving today I
think my type of leadership is to say
actually [ __ ] I I literally like had the
biggest fight with my husband an hour
ago and I forgot to put the lunch in my
kids lunchbox but I'm here today I
actually don't want to be here right now
I'm really exhausted and I don't feel
well but I'm here because I believe in
what I'm doing and I told you I was
gonna be here and I'm here and being
present in that moment and just being
honest about it I feel like people are
so thankful to be given permission to
say it isn't all perfect today and some
days you do feel great and sometimes you
don't or to admit wow maybe I changed
five times I also can feel insecure I
think we put women on this pedestal that
are you know a lot I mean forget
celebrities if you look at powerful
women they always like present
perfection but that's just not how
they're feeling inside they feel super
scared and insecure half the time and so
why not tell people how you feel right
but but they do need permission to do
that you know I would suspect that that
projection is a function of the fact
that they feel like that's what they
have to do in order to measure up
because of the double standard right
like you know I remember you saying you
know nobody asks the the male CEO like
how he balances his job with his kids
right like that's a question that you're
gonna get nine times out of ten and it's
not fair but that's the way it is so
that armor is really a reflection to
kind of immunize that woman against that
kind of that that battery of questions
or that kind of scrutiny I think that
you're absolutely right and I do and you
know I like to talk about this because I
think it's a conversation that needs to
be had in but and by the way like there
are so many men in my life that are so
important to me and have made me who I
am today and have helped me with my
business so it's not just about women
but I do think there's such an
opportunity for women to lead and you
know when I go when I go to say the side
of the soccer field or flag football
field with my son or daughter and then I
have these women that come up didn't be
like oh you're Georgie's mom oh my gosh
we've been in class with you for five
years you know whatever oh it's so nice
to finally see this sort of
condescending patronizing like we're
here all the time yeah and I think great
mom like I think I am a great mom I
don't say for the record Georgie is one
of if not the most remarkable girls I've
ever met I mean that kid is just so
talented and incredible oh my god she
blows me away every time I see her she's
gonna rule the world
well you know it's something if someone
said about my oldest daughter Phoebe my
one of my best friend said Phoebe's just
like you Greg just smarter and much
better-looking okay Georgie comes along
my son Jamison is like you know just
like the tender soul but you know what
when I say when when I'm on the side of
a soccer field and someone says that or
they say well who's taking care of your
children Greg I want to say like are you
kidding me like I am so president I know
exactly what's going on in my kids lives
every single day and we've got allow
women to say I can be a great mom and a
great wife and a great businesswoman and
let me do this and watch me shine as
opposed to judging Mac to see
I don't judge people that stay home and
I don't judge people that but doing all
of that free of that expectation of
perfection that gets laced upon you yes
I mean sometimes I'll go in I mean I
took an award the other day we won this
beauty brand and I was saying I was
exhausted so I said I got up on stage
and said you know thank God delights of
damn I have bags under my eyes and I run
a beauty business so don't don't judge
my products I'm just tired but I think
you have to talk about it you know and
just say it look I'm exhausted but I'm
doing this because I think it's
important what do people not understand
about you know someone who's running a
company of this scale and size that you
do like what is it what's the behind the
seat because we've kind of lionized the
entrepreneur and the see we're in this
sort of CEO worship culture right now I
don't know how we got here but CEOs and
entrepreneurs are like movie stars now
yeah and and everybody wants to be one
but what is the truth like I would say
truth you know like that that we might
not know from somebody who walks the
walk I did I did say to a friend of mine
it's a big actress in the last year I
said yeah I mean I'm just like you
except for I didn't get the looks or the
paycheck but yeah exactly you know I'm
not big celebrity CEO I think that I
think that what people don't realize is
how unbelievably lonely it is and and I
say that because if you're at the top of
an organization who are you turning to
you know I have an incredible executive
coach Collard who I love who's been
instrumental to my success over the last
number of years but I do think it's
really lonely I mean it's lonely at work
and it's lonely at home you know I have
a husband who has an incredibly
successful career and you know Mark and
he's an amazing husband but he's not an
entrepreneur and he doesn't often
understand what I'm going through and
the internal you know what's going on in
my head you know I want to live back at
you know 10:30 at night and say hey you
know did you end up having to fire that
person then my you know brain spins for
the next door you you can be able to
make your numbers this month you know
and he's just trying to be supportive
and I'm like
now about the weight yes try through
crazy but I think it's really really
lonely I think also as I said earlier
this as a woman trying to wanting to be
liked but knowing you have to be strong
and trying and it's hurts it really
hurts when people say you're tough [ __ ]
or whatever I don't think I am I'm an
incredibly loyal friend I actually make
readily sensitive I think most most CEOs
are really sensitive and really insecure
and people just don't realize that
because they project confidence but
that's not how they're feeling inside a
lot of the time interesting so what are
what are the big obstacles that you face
now I mean the greatest challenge for me
always is the challenge of people
managing people their wants their needs
their expectations whether it's the
independent consultants or the corporate
team my investors everyone has their own
personal agenda as they should as do I
but it's hard to to balance all that and
to be really good at it all the time I
make mistakes
every single day I so I think that's
probably one of our greatest challenges
is how do we get an organization of
people to move in unison when you're
talking about you know tens of thousands
of people and you've got a corporate
team and you've got independent
consultants and sometimes they may feel
we're misaligned even though our
intention is always to do well by our
independent consultants we make mistakes
and it's very personal for them and you
know we will look at numbers on a wall
say oh did we make our month or are we
at the best profitable as you want to be
and they're like look I'm sitting in my
kitchen in Kansas and my kids sick and
you screwed up that email and it blew my
day I mean it that's so that's been
really challenging and as we scale and I
think also tackling these issues like
when we take on things like mica these
are not insignificant issues and when
you make a promise to the world that
you're gonna tackle this you really got
to be up for the up for the fight and
it's like Everest in front of you and
trying to figure out how to navigate and
sketchy places physically corrupt people
you know it's it's hard how do you keep
your energy high for this I think that I
drank a lot of water I exercise
regularly
I hear beauties yeah exactly I do think
I will shamelessly plug our new counter
timeline that's been it's been a
game-changer for my skin but I mean I
think at the end of the day I do this
because I care deeply about what we're
doing I care about people and I care
about our health and I I want to grow
old I want my friends I want to be there
my kids you know I had kids late I want
to be there when they're getting married
or having babies and I want everyone I
love to be healthy and safe you know I I
there's there's a there's a movie called
Love Actually that many people have seen
that was about the holidays and one
things I've shown people a thousand
times is that scene that Hugh Grant's
voice over and it's a scene from
Heathrow Airport and it talks about you
know when that when the when the planes
crashed into the World Trade Center
which was a horrible day for our nation
that there weren't messages of hate
there are messages of love and at the
end of the day we that's all we care
about is like life and those that we
love and and protecting those that we
love and so that is that the at the
center of everything that we do at
beautycounter and so when you know that
that's your purpose you're gonna get out
of bed in the morning yeah and you do
and and so what are your strategies or
techniques for empowering the people
that work beneath you I think it's
helping them understand that what
they're doing is making a difference
even in those dark days and showing them
I think one of things I haven't done
well but I'm getting better at is is
showing those telling them those stories
helping to develop them to be stronger
leaders and and just knowing that that
you're making a difference I think if
you you know if you look at surveys
corporate teams or independent
consultant well however people that are
working they want to know that the work
they do is meaningful and is actually
it's Purpose Driven I mean increasingly
you hear people talk about that they
don't just want if you're gonna spend
that much time working you wanted to
have an impact on the world that's
positive and so trying to shed light on
what work we're doing the progress that
we are making even when the days are
dark to say look it's not over but we've
done so many things well and impacted so
many people's lives and you know people
should feel proud of that and we try to
have fun you know I don't take myself
that seriously like I'm you know will
once in a while we'll have a drink card
come around or we'll do goofy things in
the office if you gotta like take a
chill once in a while and settle into
the stress and know like this is a
marathon not a sprint and it's okay to
laugh if it's okay to you know not you
know to make mistakes we're gonna make
mistakes all the time let's have fun
while we're doing it for the average
person
beauty counter products aside when they
go to the pharmacy or the you know
cosmetic the sephora's of the world
they're they're trying to figure out
what to buy or what to get and they're
reading these labels and they're trying
to educate themselves like what are some
of the
worst offenders that they I'm not
talking about necessarily brand names
but like chemicals or what can they
identify that they should really you
know pay more attention to I think there
are some chemicals so anything that says
paraben methylparaben ethyl paraben
parabens are one fragrance a ghost shop
fragrance free whenever you can in in
sunscreen not to use a spray sunscreens
but to use mineral based sunscreen not
with the AVA been zone and the
oxybenzone not only not only are they
harmful to the health of people but they
are killing the coral reefs there are
things called pegs EDTA
there are those things that you can see
on labels that kind of stand out and I
think there are some great you know
brands out there that they're quite a
few and I think in so far they've now
done a clean group and even if you go to
a CBS or whatever they're gonna they're
gonna tell you I mean you know companies
like Burt's Bees and and and also if you
if you have to make decisions if you're
looking at making a purchase and you
have you know limited resources I think
you can just take a jar of organic
coconut oil or you think about the
things that are going on your body more
than the rinse off like it's more
important to worry about your body
lotion or your sunscreen and the
conditioner in your hair that's gonna
rinse out and so you can prioritize your
spend on the things that are really your
skin's your largest organ so if you're
covering yourself head-to-toe with a
lotion that's gonna seep into your skin
and into your bloodstream
I'd be focusing on those things yeah
how's the men's line I think it's good
you know the funny thing about them
people love the men's line counterman
it's been really successful in terms of
people love it that you're using it and
I think often times men think you know I
always hear well I don't wear makeup and
I'm I'm not talking about your makeup
guys I'm talking about your shave cream
your deodorant we're actually coming out
with deodorant next year which will be a
huge win but I somehow the women
sometimes get scared about selling to
men I'm like you're not selling to the
men anyway your friends it's the same
thing you know we we need to take care
of our men too they're just as important
to this equation and you know you have
so many men who follow you and you know
I don't know if you know this but just
women - I think the audience is more
more than man is it more much well good
well I'll tell the book to both groups I
think this is important you know
visa V men you know this sperm count in
the u.s. is down 50% over the last 25
years and you know
about 40% of male sperm is now defected
so if we don't think it's impacting men
it's absolutely impacting its impact on
all of us and so you know every one of
us needs to be focused on our bodies and
our safety and hopefully you know just
knowing a little bit more and I also
think that you know I say they're the
product we sell is beauty but we're
trying to sell clean lifestyle you know
a lifestyle that you live rich and I
think that just those little things like
just wash your floors with water and
vinegar take your shoes off at the door
you know get rid of the plastic
containers over time don't use non-stick
pans I mean there's some basic things
that can make a difference in your life
right out of the gate it's interesting
when you think back to being kids and
try to remember the cleaning products
that you had in your house and it was
just a couple things right but now the
typical household when you open up that
pantry or look beneath the sink or
whatever there's like 30 bottles of all
different kinds of stuff and it's like
how did we get to this point we've been
sold this idea that you need this for
this and this for that and and it's kind
of insane I was saying to my circle
cider vinegar heart and water I know and
well that's exactly I mean these things
are really basic I mean I'll sometimes
I'll be in the kitchen we'll just put
cooking you know olive oil on my skin I
think you know it's funny cuz I had my
friend Lela Rose was in town this
morning the one that originally wanted
me to watch an inconvenient truth that
we're talking about you know going into
schools and kids being you know my kids
being served Pringles and their school
like guys like why are you training them
to eat unhealthy foods like just if you
started from scratch with just healthy
foods they're not going to be looking
for these things we keep culturally
programming people to make poor
purchasing decisions for themselves if
you like Pringles I'm sorry it's just
I'm not a big Pringles fan but I think
the idea that you that less is more and
that getting back to some of the basics
is really important for right and theirs
well the reason look there's huge vested
interests and making sure kids continue
to eat Pringles and these products find
their way into schools not by accident
you know so you have to move these
gigantic tectonic you know political and
business plates in order to even get
tiny changes that we already all agree
upon enacted okay and that's the
difficulty and that's what you face
you're facing in Washington and all of
this it's like we all kind of agree that
this is a good idea
the
bill that was introduced in 2015 that
still hasn't been up for vote exactly I
mean getting people to take action is
really really difficult and you're
absolutely right you've got these large
companies that are you know they don't
want the secret the beauty secrets to be
told I mean that entire beauty industry
has been built on secrets and we're
saying no we need to build an entire
thing on transparency and authenticity
and and no [ __ ] dialogue with our
clients there's so many similarities to
the food industry you know like the in
in in agriculture there's AG gag laws
that make it illegal to go inside these
slaughterhouses and take photographs or
videos because it's too threatening to
the industry so it's the antithesis of
transparency you know and right the idea
that you're trying to shine a light on
this and are met with resistance is
bananas it's yeah I can be scary
sometimes trying to mean shine the light
on these things because they make him
literally be scary I mean shining the
light on my good it's just that's a
scary thing to do but you know someone
has to do it and were the people that
are gonna do it and I think that we
deserve to have safe products is that
well certainly Millennials and Gen Z you
know these things are much more
important to the younger generations
than they were to us when we were coming
up and that leaves me very hopeful about
the future and that purchasing power is
so powerful right and that's really
going to drive markets and to the extent
that you can at a minimum you know serve
the younger people that are coming up
and make sure that you are you know
meeting those transparency expectations
and those sustainability expectations
etc all the way down the line that
positions you for long term success
because I really think that is the
future and you're somebody who's
established yourself as being able to
forecast these things well in advance
yeah I do think that the future
generations are depending on us to do
the right thing and they're they are
demanding it of us the younger
generations and we have no choice
you know we have we have to change we
have to figure out a way to lead
businesses that are doing well and doing
good simultaneously there's there's got
to be a better path forward and I think
that you know you speak about the food
industry and I you know someone said to
me a couple years ago do you think that
clean beauty is a
add mm or a trend and I said no the
clean beauty is the future it is the
here and the now and the forever and in
the same way that no one's gonna say oh
please put all that food dye back in my
mac and cheese no one's gonna say oh
please put all these toxic chemicals the
numbing agents into my baby shampoo
again let's just do the right thing and
and I think one of them my personal
goals with beautycounter is to show that
you can be successful as a B corporation
as a company is doing well maybe we
don't make as much money as other
companies but that's okay like we can
still be a strong financial you know
business over time that that will last
forever and you know I think that's
that's critically important to the
future of Commerce yeah I mean I think
with iterative innovation you know you
get to that point where where the
product that you're offering with
natural ingredients becomes
indistinguishable with you know what
they've come to expect with the chemical
Laden version of that in the same way
we're seeing that with food right now
right I always say to you know when
people say when are you gonna stop and
to me it's when we when we stop when our
children and our children's children
don't need to worry about reading the
labels and the products that they use on
their bodies every day right and when
we're all grandparents and they say
remember when they used to put all that
cream I don't often used to put it on
your skin I can't I can't wait for
somebody to be able to say that
unfortunately they right now there's
it'll be like you know when you when you
watch Mad Men and you know the the
pregnant woman is smoking I never and
you're like how did that happen right I
think we're gonna look bad my I'm
hopeful and and optimistic that that
will be the case I think that it's
already happening I mean I have seen
just an unbelievable amount of you know
I mean the changes that have happened in
the beauty industry since I launched in
March of 13 and even over the last two
years have been pretty significant and
when you see all of the big guys talking
about it now you know that this is they
know this is here to stay and they're
they're are they're gonna be first to
change that they're not gonna be around
yeah well there's but there's a
difference between the greenwashing that
you see where they make the marketing
materials and the labels all kind of
look like they're doing the right thing
or they say the right thing but it's not
actually the right thing well goes back
to that Alabang right here's your allo
product that has no Alan and I know I
always say you know that's one of the
things you know people
said well why don't you have you know
flowers and trees and Lee I'm like no
because that's always misleading it's
not about it's not about pretending like
you are it's like just just give them a
product that works it's safe right
full-stop all right well let's let's
round this out I think it would be good
to leave people with a few words of
wisdom laden from your experience to the
budding entrepreneurs and solopreneurs
and environmental activists out there
what is the advice that you commonly
give to people who are coming up I think
that and this is probably more geared
towards women the men but I think it's
true of everyone is that you genuinely
have everything that you need to be an
enormous success and that it is about
just a lot of hard work and that
overnight success is like 10 years of
24/7 but I do think so many people doubt
themselves and they they listen to
others and I would be here to say if you
believe in something you can do it and
you've got this you've absolutely got it
you just have to stay the course and
know that there gonna be some dark
moments in time yeah and which I don't
think enough people are saying that
especially to women I don't think enough
people are saying you have everything
you need to be successful you've got
what it takes I think a lot of people
doubt themselves and I'm always here to
say if your mom didn't tell you that if
your husband didn't tell you that or
whatever I'm here to tell you you've got
it and I think that's a really important
message I also think that if you're
trying to build something you're your
own personal self awareness is important
know where you're strong and know where
you're weak and find people to to
support you in the areas in which you're
not strong don't try to lean you know
pretend you're good at everything as an
entrepreneur entrepreneurs do that a lot
of the time they don't want to show
weakness or vulnerability they're scared
to admit that they don't have all the
answers but there's no one has all the
answers and so to the extent that you
can acknowledge where you're not as
strong and then find people who can get
you those answers that makes you a lot
better surround yourself with people
more expert in their in those areas that
you can also trust right and trust your
gut I mean I think it's so many the
mistakes I've made a long way with
beautycounter are the times in which
when I listen to people and I knew in my
heart that they were yeah I was kind of
you know even being bullied in my own
company of people telling me that I was
wrong or you know I didn't know what I
was doing and now I'm like them [ __ ]
I'm gonna like stick with my gut and if
I
think you know we haven't we haven't we
have something at beautycounter that I
think has served as well and so if
people are running their own businesses
or you know or even in your partnerships
in life you know we have something we
always say are you willing to fall on
your sword on this one like you cared
this deeply about this issue or about
this initiative about this thing that
you're willing to fall on your sword if
you're wrong and I've found that when
people say yes and I do it myself we all
do it now
that 99.9 percent of the time that
people are right and so and when I say
the team hey guys I know you can't see
this but just trust me trust me on this
one
those are the moments in which I know
I'm right and and and I'd do the same
for my teammates and if you're not right
and you fall on that sword that's okay
that's okay too I mean you're gonna be
wrong sometimes but I do think most the
time people are right and and I also you
know we talked about this a little bit
earlier and this isn't necessarily these
aren't words of wisdom but I think it's
so important just to remind people that
you can be a great mom and work and via
great spouse and you can do all these
things and maybe it's just not all in
the same day so we tend to put so much
pressure on ourselves to be perfect all
the time you know there are days when
I'm not with my family and I'm
facetiming them and in their days when
I'm completely home and not at the
office and I think that I want
especially women to stay in the game and
to know that they can do it even if it's
on a part-time basis whatever they want
to do that staying in the game is
important and that you can be great at
both and it's not it doesn't have to be
one or the other they're not they're not
necessarily mutually exclusive I wish
more people knew that and had the
confidence to to do both yeah there's
this pressure not only to excel but to
have everything in perfect balance all
the time because that's the message that
we've been that we've been sold and we
shoulder that ourselves thinking like we
have to be the best parent and the best
at everything every single day every
hour of the day and that's not life
nobody's in that position and then we
beat ourselves up because on a
particular day we fell short in one of
those categories right be there for the
important moments in your business be
there for your improvements moments in
life well what you've created and the
mission is super inspiring I've so much
respect for you and I just also want to
say for the record you've been an
incredible resource of advice and help
for
in her in her cheese lunch Remo so thank
you for that she values your advice
tremendously and you've been very very
helpful so she's gonna crush it it's
it's pretty amazing so I'm sorry
well I again I think women have to
support women that's really important to
me and so I'm always gonna be there for
her all right cool we'll come back and
talk to me again sometime okay thanks
for having it if you're diggin on Greg
you can go to beauty counter comm or you
can find her on stage yeah you won't
find her on the website maybe yeah
on Instagram Greg Renfrew and Twitter as
well and if somebody's listening who
wants to become involved with the
company how do they do that they go your
website and sign up how does that work
yeah they can go the website and sign up
or they can always you know email our
offices info beauty counter comm we're
always happy to talk to you cool
all right well thanks so much thanks all
right peace
[Music]